what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be telling you the story of how I got
started on social media and how I
figured out what my passion in life is
it all started maybe four years ago when
I was working the sales job and I was
selling copiers and I'm telling you if
there's one job you don't want to do it
is selling copiers that's a horrible job
horrible shout out to my old employer
yeah no offense I was working this job
and I thought it was horrible and I was
trying to figure out what I wanted to do
with my life so what I did was I wrote
down all of the things that I would do
when I was alone some things in life you
do because other people like them so
like for example for me hiking that's
something I like to do with my family
but I would never do that by myself so
what I did was I wrote down the things
that I like to do when I was alone and
that I would spend my time on even if no
one was there and what I wrote down was
YouTube sports playing volleyball and
music and so it was a couple years ago I
decided to start taking steps towards
each of these goals I started did
signing myself up for guitar lessons I
reached out to this rude manager from
the daily wire who ignored me left me on
scene can you believe that scene and I
applied to play Semi-Pro volleyball
overseas what happened was in July I had
just downloaded Tick Tock and I thought
it would be funny to post the story of
how my parents brought this brought this
like industrial sized water slide
basically my dad is like insane so
basically this water slide paralyzed guy
and my dad was like oh it's on sale let
me buy it and it was just this whole
story of how he put up the slide and the
whole town wanted him to like take it
down it was it was this whole thing but
to make a long story short that video
got four million views and what I
realized is I was like oh I think I'm
good at the storytelling and like
talking stuff and at that point I was
still working at my sales job I had been
ignored ignored by someone I won't name
names but if I had to name names I won't
do it I won't do you like that but I was
ignored yeah I was left unseen but that
was when like the ball was rolling I was
like I'm actually good at social media
and this was like in my first five tick
tocks that I've ever posted I got
millions of views telling the story so
after that I was trying everything like
I was just dabbling at all different
types of content because I'm I can be
very sporadic so I just have a lot of
different interests so I would talk
about sports I would talk about I did
relationship quizzes I almost got a
national TV for making a quiz that you
could send to your ex-boyfriend or
girlfriend with like a survey basically
talking about why we broke up millions
of views off of this stuff almost on I
was like in the final rounds of going on
the Kelly Clarkson show I don't know if
they'd have me on anymore
but but back then I was like they didn't
even know who they were talking to yet
and what happened was during this time I
decided I wanted to play overseas I was
thinking okay maybe I could start a
little YouTube channel make money from
that and make money from playing
volleyball and like do that both so I
applied to this was during like the so
bad like I think it was 2020 of October
I applied to start season in January of
2021 and so what I did was I quit my job
in October kind of to be a YouTuber but
also because I was going to play
overseas at that point I didn't even
have a YouTube channel really um I
hadn't posted but I just decided I was
going to do YouTube and Tick Tock my mom
was thrilled
um I didn't even the funny thing is when
I quit my job I didn't even tell my mom
I was moving home I just decided and but
it was only supposed to be from October
to January I saved up a bunch of money
to go and I was ready and then the
season got canceled so in January it was
supposed to be moved to September so
what was supposed to be like a
three-month unemployment turned into a
year so what I was thinking is okay I
moved home already I could get a job for
a year or I could just be a social media
person and and at the time my plan was
Tick Tock so I posted a couple tick
tocks of my mom organizing our clothes
just different organizational type house
content and how she designed our house
and people thought it was really
interesting so my first like big YouTube
video that got my channel monetized was
my mom giving a house tour that was like
the first one that I did but then I
started doing like rap reaction videos
and music reaction videos and just a
bunch of different like reaction videos
that was interesting too until I also I
forgot this one I also went door to door
in rich neighborhoods looking for a job
I didn't actually want a job and I'm
pretty sure my old employer was like
this girl quit no I didn't actually want
a job I wanted to be unemployed but I
wanted to see if I could get one going
door to door in rich neighborhoods um I
did a couple public interviews but the
next thing that like blew me up was rap
reactions and I ended up getting like 10
000 followers in a day reacting to rap
music and then how I got into manosphere
content was I was sent a Kevin Samuels
video and what was interesting to me is
they were talking about high value men
cheating and my dad he's like four out
of the five of the things high value men
are like he doesn't he doesn't have
social media so he doesn't have like the
LinkedIn visibility but like the income
the all the things that Kevin Samuels
listed he had so I was like I called my
dad and I'm like Dad where are your
[ __ ] where are your hoes they said
you're supposed to have a leather of
women and my dad was like okay well tell
them to get one wife before they try
four and so so that was what like it was
funny if you look at the first Kevin
Samuels video I did I really didn't like
him because I was like stop saying my
dad's cheating what are you talking
about but I came to realize that Kevin
Samuel's point is that if you get a guy
with like he's handsome good-looking
attractive uh basically like like a top
five two percent guy and you're not
youthful and you're not pure how on
Earth would you expect monogamy it took
me a while but I did understand that
concept later but at first I was
triggered I was just like the girls on
my show I was triggered so yeah and then
I was just really interested in how men
thought it was was just so interesting
to hear like the men's point of view on
everything because as a girl like we
think of things from our point of view I
was like oh my gosh dating is hard for
men but it's like as a woman that never
occurs to you
what happened was I started reacting to
Alpha Male strategies Rolo tomasi Poor
Man's podcast just a bunch of different
like red pill content creators I started
watching and I even reacted to a couple
pickup artists like um John Anthony
lifestyle I ended up going to his boot
camp and doing a whole Vlog of like
seeing what it's like for a guy going to
like a boot camp to try to learn how to
get laid I was like oh this is so
interesting I did that until I left for
England and then when I moved to England
I did reactions for a couple more months
then what happened was in March I had
this idea and what I was thinking was I
had never lived in a country that was so
or a city or a place that was just so
diverse I could meet someone from Italy
I can meet someone from Nigeria I can
meet someone from Spain all just like
walking down the street and I thought
that was so so cool I thought it would
be so interesting to bring in all these
people that we have nothing in common
except relationships that's the one
thing everyone has in common every girl
can talk to other girls about dating
guys every guy can talk to other guys
about dating girls and they'll have
similar experiences so I was like why
don't we just battle it out because I
kind of understand things from Men's
point of view but at the same time like
men don't always understand the woman's
point of view so I was like let's bring
the men and the women and let's just
talk about different topics like do
women like nice guys do men actually
like nice girls vice versa and yeah that
was that was how the show was born so
that was great and it was you know it
was going okay for a little bit but the
video that like blew up my channel that
that sort of started this whole wave a
lot of people don't actually know what
video was but it was actually I
introduced my friend to the red pill for
the first time that was a girl that I
had on the show
um her name's Jess we live together now
but at the time this was a girl on my
basketball team I remember thinking just
how reasonable she was but a lot of the
things she thought just were kind of
like brainwashing like not true and
maybe she just if I showed her certain
content like she might look at the world
a different way in the early stages we
talked about things like trans people in
like women's sports and I was explaining
to her that if they're in our sports
like that's the end of women's sports
because they're always going to beat us
and she was like oh I just never thought
of it that way and she changed her
opinion so I was like I wonder if I
showed her Thomas Sowell Jordan Peterson
and some of these other great thinkers
like if that would change your view on
the world I started showing the stuff to
her and it's interesting because you
just could see it like this is one of my
favorite parts of the show is like when
you see people's minds change and just
their whole world view switch right in
front of your eyes and so that was the
first video that blew up my channel and
then the clip started to go viral oh I
forgot to put in the part my manager now
did respond to me eventually after a
year so he's when did you start managing
me yeah it was like two years ago they
had me in the first half I was you know
the underdog no one believed in me on my
own
um a couple parts I did skip over I did
meet with Kevin Samuels twice before he
passed away and he also gave me some
advice for my channel Donovan sharp also
helped me with my channel early on I was
on a show for him pretty early but I
don't know I never really set out to do
YouTube like from when I was a kid I
never really knew what I wanted to do I
thought it was sales at first but it was
kind of like when I posted that first
water slide video I was just thinking
huh I have something here I might be
good at it and it's actually crazy how
out in six months your whole life can
change because six months ago I kind of
hated my life because I was doing
everything for the show myself and now
it's a lot better because I have like
help we have a whole team but it's just
kind of crazy how it was like six months
ago I had a manager in another country
and I just got three microphones put
them on a table and told people to start
talking and now we're in a whole studio
with the whole producer you know follow
your dreams because you never know you
never know what could happen what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
don't forget to like the video subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell and we'll talk to you next time